die Preise steigen weiter die
Energiekrise spitzt sich zu aber wir
lassen niemanden allein wir haben einen
Plan das hat Olaf Scholz seit Beginn der
teuer Krise immer wieder betont doch wie
sieht dieser Plan aus die horenden
Energiekosten die bringen schon jetzt
viele kleine und mittlere Betriebe ans
existenzlimit in der Sendung Illner wird
Scholz gestern von Bäckerin Cornelia
stiebling gefragt was wollen Sie tun um
die kleinen und mittleren
Familienbetriebe am Leben zu halten
wir werden nicht alle Preise runter
subventionieren können ich glaube so
viel Wahrheit gehört dazu das kann kein
Staat der Welt das können auch wir nicht
obwohl wir über erheblich mehr
finanzielle Möglichkeiten verfügen als
viele andere ja das sind keine unbedingt
guten Nachrichten aber die Regierung
helfe ja mit Tankrabatt 9 Euro Ticket
EEG-Umlage
aber es muss natürlich auch so sein dass
man sich das Leben leisten kann
ja das war ein wünschen wir uns alle
dass wir uns das Leben leisten können
wir sprechen jetzt mit dem
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordneten Johannes alt
hier im Studio schön dass Sie hier sind
Herr alt viele Deutsche machen sich
Sorgen viele Deutsche blicken mit großer
Angst in den Herbst und andere können
schon jetzt ihre Rechnungen nicht
bezahlen wir wollen es aber weiterhin
wir wollen nicht in die Armut abrutschen
was muss getan werden
ja ich kann verstehen dass viele mit
sorgen in die Zukunft blicken wir haben
eine sehr große Inflation die vor allen
Dingen durch Energiekosten getrieben ist
teilweise auch durch
lebensmittelpreissteigerungen und jetzt
was wir jetzt machen als Bundesregierung
als koalitionsfraktion es sind zwei
Dinge wir sagen einmal kurzfristig wir
haben zwei entlastungspakete ja
verabschiedet die kosten ungefähr 30
Milliarden Euro die wir dort investieren
dieses Jahr und das interessante dabei
ist ja viele sagen ja es reicht noch
nicht aus aber viele der Maßnahmen
greifen ja noch gar nicht viele
auszahlungen sind noch gar nicht erfolgt
weil die wirken für die Menschen auch
noch gar nicht zum Beispiel ist
energiegeld was er erst im September
ausgezahlt wird weil jetzt werden für
Grundsicherungsempfänger für Rentner für
wohngeld-empfänger in diesem Monat
Zahlungen gemacht
um kurzfristig zu helfen und langfristig
gucken wir dass wir unabhängig von
fossiler Energie werden haben deshalb
gestern über 20 Gesetze geändert um
langfristig in Deutschland eben
klimaneutral Energie selber produzieren
zu können also im Hintergrund vielleicht
nicht immer sichtbar da rödelt und
wuschelt man und sucht Lösungen und
versucht Dinge auf dem Weg zu bringen
dennoch der Kanzler sagt wir werden
nicht Nobelpreise runter subventionieren
können das klingt so ein bisschen auch
nach Pech gehabt auch Eigenverantwortung
es kommt auch dicke und wir können auch
nicht alles tun dreht sich das richtig
raus ja es ist richtig sie ist am
Haushaltsentwurf schon so dass es quasi
ganz wichtig ist dass wir soziale
Sicherheit die äußere Sicherheit und die
gesellschaftliche Sicherheit eben
gemeinsam denken oder das ist ganz ganz
wichtig da kannst du halt vom unterhaken
gesprochen und darum gibt es jetzt auch
eine sogenannte konzertierte Aktion das
heißt sich der Kanzler mit
Arbeitnehmervertretern mit
arbeitgebervertretern trifft regelmäßig
in kurzen Abständen um wirklich zu
beraten alle paar Wochen was können wir
jetzt tun was ist jetzt noch
erforderlich wie müssen wir diese
Maßnahmen anpassen weil wir können das
noch nicht absehen was im Herbst und
Winter kommen wird was wir brauchen das
ist wichtig dass wir schnell reden und
handlungsfähig bleiben aber es droht
eine neue Armut stimmen Sie dazu
es droht in jedem Fall für viele
Haushalte eine Situation in der es
ziemlich hart wird Energierechnung zu
bezahlen das stimmt schon also sprich in
Deutschland werden Menschen vor
Rechnungen entstehen die sie nicht
begleichen können
das hoffe ich nicht wird aber im
Einzelfall sicherlich vorkommen so
ehrlich muss man sein ja was wollen sie
den Menschen sagen die jetzt schon Angst
und Bange haben gibt es wir hören immer
so Duschen sie kürzer achten Sie auf die
Lichtschalter kaufen Sie weniger ein was
sind Tipps womit man
vielleicht sich irgendwie rüsten kann
für den Herbst für den Winter für all
die Menschen gehen jetzt angst und bange
wird naja weniger Einkaufen das wäre
also sollte keiner an die Lebensmittel
sparen sofern das möglich ich weiß dass
manche Menschen auch das tun müssen und
das natürlich ganz ganz dramatisch ich
hoffe jetzt einfach dass die Maßnahmen
wirken die wir geben wir haben ja ganz
ganz viele Entlastung wir haben zum
ersten siebten EEG-Umlage abgeschafft
das sind schon mal vier Cent knapp pro
Kilowattstunde die auf der Stromrechnung
wegfallen ja und viele andere
entlastungsmechanismen die jetzt wirken
und ich hoffe dass sie bei den Menschen
wirklich ankommen ansonsten müssen wir
nachlegen das hoffen wir alle noch ein
paar positive Worte zum Schluss denn wir
haben auch so schöne Bilder in dieser
Sendung geschaut die Hochzeit von
Christian Lindner und Franka Lehfeldt
genießen Sie das auch mal abseits des
politischen Trubels solche Bilder zu
sehen oder gehören sie zur Fraktion und
sagen mein Gott ist das ein Prim
ja es ist nett es bedient so ein
bisschen ein Interesse aber wie gesagt
ich konzentriere mich darauf sehr
Politik für die Menschen mache ich freue
mich dass wir gestern beschlossen haben
dass zum Beispiel wenn man jetzt eben
sich nur Solaranlage aufs Dach packt
dass wir wenn wir über den Eigenbedarf
einspeisen ist jetzt besser vergütet
wird dass wir Wasserkraftwerke erhalten
können dass die weiter gefördert werden
die ist ja vor allen Dingen auch in
Süddeutschland gibt was diese Dinge
jetzt auf dem Weg kommt dass ich für
mich jetzt wichtiger als Christian
Lindner Seite alles klar Johannes alt
vielen herzlichen Dank für Ihren Besuch
heute morgen an diesem frühen Morgen
hier im Studio zu dringenden und
drängenden Fragen was für einen Herbst
in was für einen Winter steuern wir und
was kann die Politik tun um uns da allen
zu helfen damit Deutschland nicht in die
Armut abrutscht danke Ihnen für Ihre
Informationen vielen Dank